[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
look
this
[Music]
go
oh
[Music]
welcome welcome to the Cyber truck
delivery event so so uh I'm going to do
it from the back of the truck
[Applause]
[Music]
here so so once once in a while once in
once in a once in a long while a product
comes along that
is uh rare that is once in once every 5
to 10
years something really
special a really unusual product comes
along and we'll remember those special
moments
when
indeed
[Music]
[Applause]
um special
moments um
so but but these things are rare the
it's very rare that our product comes
along that is uh seemingly
impossible uh that that people said was
impossible that experts said was
impossible and this is one of those
times we have a we have a a car here
that xut said was impossible that xut
said would never be
made that
uh it it it really is the
most I think it's I think it's our best
product I think it's the most most
unique thing on the road and finally the
future will look like the
[Applause]
future so what what we're aiming for
here is something that has that's more
truck than
truck
okay thanks
bro that's literally my brother
[Laughter]
there so
um and and so what we have here is is
something that is a better truck than a
truck while also being a better sports
car than a sports car in the same
package
so first of all Let's uh you know they
talk about how you know trucks are tough
that's one of the defining
characteristics of a truck so how tough
is this truck
let's find
out so we actually had to come up with a
Special ultra strong uh Tesla designed
steel alloy so this alloy did this this
this metal did not exist before uh we
needed something that you could actually
manufacture but uh that that would be
have basically no
corrosion um that didn't need Paint uh
but you can still make it in volume
and part of the reason that it has this
angular shape is you can't actually
stamp these body panels the body panels
would break the stamping
machine so uh oh and I should say also
the because of the steel exoskeleton it
actually has more torsional rigidity
than a sports car it has more torsional
stiffness than a McLaren
P1 so it's that's very that's a big deal
um
now you may remember an incident four
years
ago didn't quite go as
planned and um France maybe we should
try it
[Applause]
again uh
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
Miss
yeah yeah great I mean I think you could
we could probably have a pro picture or
lava still work um so anyway it's the
there the glass is tough basically
that's what we're saying um so uh you
don't have to worry about like rocks
hitting the glass and cracking the glass
this GL this glass is is basically Rock
proof um it's also makes the car very
quiet so it's the the the thing that
you'll appreciate when you drive the car
is that is how smooth and quiet it is it
it does it feels it doesn't feel like
like a normal truck it's it's smooth as
silk and and and Silent uh when when you
drive it um and um yeah so in tough in
terms of toughness and then things like
roll over because the center of gravity
uh is so low it doesn't roll
over and if you're ever in an argument
with another car you will
win
yeah
[Applause]
so in in movies you sometimes see the
hero or heroine uh hiding behind the car
door uh while being shot with bullets
that doesn't actually work unless you're
driving a cyber
truck so uh if El Capone showed up with
a Tommy Gun and emptied the entire
magazine into the car door you would
still be alive so uh you know and so
people say like well you know why' you
make it bulletproof I'm like why
not you want to how tough is your truck
because the the the other trucks the
bullets go through both sides so uh you
shoot a bullet goes through both sides
of the car um and uh you know you never
know I
mean sometimes you get these like late
civilization
Vibes you you never know when the
apocalypse could come come along at any
moment and um at here Tesla we have the
finest in Apocalypse uh
technology
uh I was on The Joe Rogan show and uh
Joe bet me a dollar that his armor
piercing steel head Arrow would go
through the car it uh he now he owes me
a
dollar now what about utility
so strength is great but is this is this
a you know perhaps just a show truck uh
just a
you know a showpiece or can it do actual
work how does it work as a real everyday
truck well here we have the future
Towing the
future
so uh if basically if you can fit uh any
Cargo in in the in the trunk or in the
bed you you can basically move it around
so it's got uh over a ton of uh payload
cap ility but you could really put more
than that in it uh you can tow over
11,000 lb um and it's got a super tough
composite bed no liner needed the bed is
6ot long 4ot wide and you can fit um 4x8
F 4x8 pieces of plywood in with the with
the uh with the back
down so um for those who are really into
the truck world there's there's
something uh in the truck world called a
a truck pull this is really the the key
test of how much power does your truck
actually have so you have to pull this a
40,000 lb
sled and uh when we went to the track we
said well well what's the
best that that you've seen they said
well it's it be the fourth F350 Diesel
was like well let's let's put our truck
up against that the the guy who runs the
the truck pool said that's there no way
there's no way it's like well let's try
it let's see what
[Music]
happens
standing around the
[Applause]
[Music]
volan
we actually had to slightly turn the car
at the end so it didn't hit the
wall so this uh you have here a car that
is uh you know um bull bullet tough uh
you know like that phrase TM um and uh
can outpull an F350 Diesel
uh has a massive towing capacity massive
bed uh one it's basically an incredibly
useful truck it's not just some Grand
standing showpiece like me um uh it's
actually it's actually very
useful now what about
performance so this I should say it's it
has an Adaptive air suspension so no
matter what the load is uh you it will
you can always have the it can set the
the right height at any at low height
anything it'll automatically adjust the
damping according to uh how much load
it's carrying and the road conditions uh
has a 17inch ground clearance now that's
a true 17 in that with typically with a
truck you'll you'll get the differential
hanging down low uh the rear
differential and that's what you'll
highight on a rock uh but this is this
has a completely flat bed so so you
could you could uh drive over basically
anything we actually did took the cber
truck on a Baja rally
drive so this is insane off-road
capability it has locking differentials
rear talk
vectoring uh and the crazy thing is
they'll do this all in
Comfort um it has steer by wire which is
if it's one of the things where most
people don't know that means but um it's
what it's how modern jets are designed
the steer by wire which gives you
variable gain so if you turn the wheel a
small the steering the steering yolk a
small amount in the parking lot it will
turn the wheels a lot but if you if you
turn it on on a highway it turns the
wheels a small amount so it it
dynamically adjusts how how much the
wheels turn according to uh what your
speed is um and this actually makes it
very easy to drive it actually and it
has a turning Circle less than a Model
S so this thing can p practically turn
it you know rotate on a you know dime
basically um it has incredible low-
speed
maneuverability and then uh there's a
lot of advanced details Under the Skin
uh it's the first time that a car is
moving to a 48volt low voltage
architecture from 12 volts which has
been around for 100
years um
we have ethernet coms uh distributed
controllers allows for 70% less wire in
the car um and it's uh it's really the
the internals are as advanced as the
externals it's it's a a whole new Step
changeing
technology so let's take it to the
racetrack and see how how does the Cyber
truck perform against the Porsche
911 and and I I should say this is this
is an actual Porsche we literally just
got it from the dealer 2023 Porsche
911 woo
but wait there's
[Applause]
more so
the
[Applause]
it can it can tow a Porsche 911 across a
quarter mile faster than the pors 911
can grow by
itself I should say tougher than bullets
uh tow pretty much anything uh faster
than 911 while towing a
911 so uh and deliveries bring begin now
thank
[Applause]
you
[Music]
so
he
own going to come
up so we're just these are the actual
owners we're heading over production
cyber trucks to their actual owners
thank you for buying cyber
[Music]
truck oh
hi hi sure
absolutely uh just open the I think
there we go you got me the best
driver thank
[Music]
you thank
you
[Music]
well as you can see we've got quite a
few to deliver here
so hi thank you I haven't slept in 3
days oh wow okay
welcome hope you enjoy your
[Music]
car right
all right hey hey good to see you here
good
yeah enjoy your truck thank you so much
yeah just uh
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
well this is a delivery event you
know thank you that's
me
great is this is the button for open it
and that's
[Music]
it I mean it's going to be amazing to
see all these cars driving
around incredible than you man I
appreciate you most welcome
so I just press this but button
here all right appreciate you
welcome I mean this this is really going
to change the look of the roads I mean
one of in a parking lot one of them does
not look like the
other so
hey see I love your hey how's it going
fun hey yeah
welcome
thank you
rightow
[Music]
is that
it two
more
[Music]
welcome
drive all right thank you everyone uh uh
thanks for coming to the Cyber truck L
event um and uh you witness to
what oh one more okay sorry
okay
uh go ahead and drive it out
actually looks like
maybe
[Music]
I
it's all right you want to drive it uh
yeah sure okay all
right all right thanks everyone for
coming to this uh delivery event and
uh appreciate your support um
and uh this is really going to like said
change the look of the roads and finally
the future will look like the future and
it's really going to be something
special thank
[Music]
you
w